there's a new trend in advertising where
companies they don't just talk about
their product but instead they address
social issues they think are important
like bullying or racism drunk driving
right stuff like that I mean important
issues yeah but you think you're
watching an ad for a product and then
they just talk about that you know it's
kind of interesting now a lot of the ads
are really good they're serving a good
purpose but there's one I saw this
weekend that seems to be addressing an
issue I don't think anyone's even
thinking about check this out
[Music]
so yeah we're Irish
so I may not have given you the largest
penis in the world but you've got a
perfectly good wiener
don't let anyone make fun of it dad
why are you talking about me knob
because I love you too good penis good
day
[Music]
first of all that's a myth about the
Irish not true
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you